there's one thing that surprises me the
most about this show I feel like every
two to three episodes this show makes me
cry even when it's one of the really
cheesy episodes something will happen
that'll make me cry and anything to do
with parental figures especially gets to
me
happy Monday reject nation Greg Alba
here today gonna be doing a trailer
reaction for season five of the flash H
so I watched all the season four I tried
doing those 10-minute cuts for the
reactions of season four to put up on
YouTube majority of them have been
blocked when I started doing them I
tried all the methods that everyone
recommended only 20 second intervals per
scene or whatever I've tried a bunch of
different versions of it and they just
kept getting blocked I don't know how
some channels get away with it when I
applied their exact method on our
patreon we do full-length TV show
reactions to many TV shows and the flash
is one of the majority of the episodes
of season for that watch lungs are all
on our patreon just finish season for a
little bit before Comic Con and I'm late
to this trailer now really quick I did
enjoy season four I thought DeVoe was a
great villain and I loved the
cliffhanger at the end minora I'm
excited to see what's in store I kind of
rank the flash season four as the third
best season I prefer it over season
three but I could still prefer one and
two let's hop right into this
that is such a cool thing that's it
we'll see excited when I saw that yeah
we need to talk
I'm your daughter Nora future she's a
cutie just me
oh nice I mean even me when I was a kid
and kind of stuck here now
why so anybody know what to do this is
so weird
I can't believe that's their daughter up
there no I shouldn't be here she could
marty mcfly herself out of existence she
needs to be good points thirty years
from them not us no no what I need to
know okay this is that bad
please why'd you keep this from us I
think I made a big thing
what there's always so many mistakes
that they keep making who account with
us any worse that's gonna be crazy see
Wally
[Music]
I don't have a suit actually I have a
backup
Darth Vader
[Music]
what we got in store here
[Music]
oh go yeah I heard about that did hear
about that part
I kick ass villain dude
you know it's gonna be a hybrid of
cheese some darkness some humor some
tears some intensity I love this show I
heard Chris Klein is gonna be playing
chippy it's chick kata is how you
pronounce it I do want to say kick
hotter but I have a feeling that is
wrong Chris Klein who I haven't seen
since the movie just friends that is a
movie that more people should watch by
the way read about how he has those
trademark lightning bolt daggers he sort
of used he metahumans as an epidemic and
he wants to exterminate them one at a
time which I think really ups the ante
for the amount of people team flash is
gonna have to protect this season cuz I
like what they did with them having to
find all those specific metahumans at
the vote was after and trying to protect
them and in this season they've set it
up as he's gonna be pretty much trying
to wipe out all the metahumans which
means the stakes are that much higher
and of course the flash frame which I
heard about many years ago which is such
an integral part of the flash suit that
allows him to suit up even easier which
I'm excited about no fans have been
wanting the flash ring in the show for a
long time so to get it here is really
sweet but it's the noir dynamic I'm most
interested in and seeing how this all
plays out because if there's one thing
that surprises me the most about this
show I feel like every two to three
episodes this show makes me cry even
when it's one of the really cheesy
episodes something will happen that'll
make me cry and anything to do with
parental figures especially gets to me
there's quite a good mystery set up and
I'm kind of questioning some stuff of
why Nora can't time travel back to her
time because clearly she's in touch with
the Speed Force I figured she should be
able to just do it so I'm sure there'll
be a bunch of cool episodes and
mysteries to unravel there but I'm just
really looking forward to seeing Barry
and iris form the relationship with this
version of Nora knowing the show it's
probably going to evolve in a way where
you're like I can see Barry and iris
being this girl's parents and she just
seems so funny I love when she's looking
around the lab it's kind of like she's
walking into a museum of the flash she
kind of seems like a fan of her father
it's an element that I haven't really
seen explored in these comic book movies
or shows so that's something I'm very
much looking forward to seeing play out
I even think it would be fun if you
I've been going to counseling thinking
before them in that therapy session
together he did see some Kid Flash near
some Wally West I know he was kind of
gone for a lot of the season I'm not
really caught up today with DC's legends
of tomorrow I heard he's in that show
now but I'm wondering if this season
he'll make a few more appearances either
way this plot line that they teased for
what season five has in store has me
incredibly enthusiastic I I don't think
there's been a season yet of the flash
where I haven't started it yet but I'm
genuinely thrilled to see what they have
in store based off the information I
know I can't wait to check it out
probably continue doing reactions on our
page route for that anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell check us out on
patreon talk to you later